- Let's close up the show with a story
I promise we'll bring you total delight
and if not, we tried.
This is What I'm Liking.
(audience applauding)
On this show, I've come across
a number of unusual
emotional support animals.
Sure, there's the
traditional pug or Chihuahua,
I might I've even seen pigs and horses,
but a Florida college
graduate says she could never
have accomplished getting her master's
without the emotional support of her rat,
that's right, I said rat
and he's adorable with a little hat guys.
Little Remy named after
the movie Ratatouille
has been at Sarah's side
since her first semester in grad school,
which you know, her roommate was like,
"cool, I got that chick,"
which is why when it was time
to take her graduation photos,
Sarah was sure Remy was
right there with her.
We have Sarah and Remy on the line now.
What's up y'all?
- Hi, I'm good, how are you?
- I am not in a cool place like you,
you look like you're in
some kind of cool attic,
in some movie I want to
be in, looks really cool.
- Just at home.
- Okay, how did Remy come into your life?
- Well, I've struggled
with anxiety for a while,
so when I started graduate school,
my friends classes were during
the day, mine were at night,
so then additional struggles of isolation
started to sneak in.
I grew up on a farm,
where you going?
I grew up on a farm so anytime
I felt stressed or anxious,
I would go out with my animals,
have my quiet time with God.
And in talking with counselors,
we came to the conclusion of
an emotional support animal.
And my friend who had rats
introduced me to them,
and that led to me rescuing Remy.
I was definitely skeptical at first,
but instantly fell in love with her.
- Oh my gosh. I'm gonna
be honest with you,
I wasn't in until now.
I wanna snuggle with Remy, that's so cute.
So wait, how do people react to you,
having Remy as an emotional support pet?
When a lot of people are trying
to rid them from their houses,
I don't know anyone or maybe me.
- Yeah, the typical initial reaction
is "ew or that's weird."
But once people meet Remy, they love her.
I got her right before the pandemic hit,
so when I was in class
virtually or studying,
she'd be with me and she's a small,
but very significant reminder to me that
in those moments of anxiety
and feeling isolated,
I'm not alone and that God's plans
are bigger than my moments of weakness.
- Oh my God, she's adorable
with the hat, oh my gosh!
Thank you so much, Sarah, I'm
liking your posts right now.
- [Sarah] Thank you.
- I don't even know you,
we just met, but I'm so proud of you.
What a way to like do an
amazing thing with your life,
Good luck in life, all right.
- Thank you so much.
- All right well, and bye Remy!
That, it's kind of funny
cause my son's name is Remy,
I'm gonna tell him I met
a rat named Remy today,
he's gonna love it, and
that's not all though,
our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
the Go-to Pen of The Kelly Clarkson Show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers, just like you ma'am,
so they're gonna be using their G2 gel pen
to write you a check for a 1,000 dollars.
How does that sound?
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, oh my goodness!
Well, thank you, thank
you so much and good luck!